I need a team of good agents.
But I just have
the Slow Horses.
Alright make this quick.
I've got underlings
to bully. I’m busy.
No one in
Slough House is busy.
Come on, get on with it.
A team from MI5
has gone rogue…
and Standish has
been taken.
What's the plan?
[pants zipped]
I need a team
of good agents.
But I just have
the slow horses.
And the traitors we’re
looking for are ex-military.
There will
be a reckoning.
Go! Go!
You can wipe
your slate clean.
Okay.
There's another
game being played
that will probably
leave me worse off.
I just can't see
what this one is yet.
[car alarm chirps]
It's an honor to be
selected for field work.
Shut up.
Got it.
Really?
Check the CCTV.
I'd be amazed if you
hadn't missed something.
I still have oversight
of the slow horses.
[guns click]
[car alarm chirps]
Lucky me.
♪
There are men
outside with guns.
Some backup
might be handy.
Well, I'm busy.
Okay. Thanks.
I'm sure the situation
will resolve itself.
♪
MI5 betrayed us.
Justice is
coming their way.
♪
We have to limit
the collateral damage.
Everyone in that facility
is coming out
in a body bag.
-You’re smiling?
-Yeah. I feel alive, don’t you?
[gunshots]
♪
What would you have done?
I would have killed
every one of them.
If they threatened to kill
you on the other hand
I’d buy 'em a
beer and the bullets.
[car door slams]
[sighs]
Go on, out you get.